need motivation watch top ten with
believe nation what's that believe
nation it's seven I believe in you and
this channel is designed to be a part of
your daily success routine so let's get
your motivation to attend and get you
believing in you grab a snack enjoy
today's lessons from a man who went from
being a college dropout to a
multi-millionaire at age 24 and being
the co-founder of elite daily a
publication with over 80 million people
reading it every single month
he's gerard adams and here's my take on
his top ten rules of success
okay let's kick it off with rule number
one seas today I feel life is short like
I feel like a lot of people don't
recognize like
really the universe is billions and
billions of years and yet we have you
know my grandfather just celebrate his
99th birthday I was like that was
amazing and going oh yeah we're going at
definitely he's definitely going above
100 and hopefully I hopefully I have
that we don't have you know he said to
me a minute when I hang hot hung out
with him he just really reiterated he
just like Gerard first of all he's like
there is no tomorrow
there is only today only today and
everything so many of you so many of you
are waiting for tomorrow instead of
actually thinking about what you want to
create today rule number two
take risks what is the like value of
risk for an entrepreneur like the the
ability to take risk it's everything
it's part of my DNA you know it's just
like I'm constantly every day trying to
challenge myself you know to push myself
to take risk whether it's in my personal
life you know pushing myself to new
environments
trying new things and white eating you
the people it helps me grow you know I
grow as an individual every time I try
to do something that scares me I just
like in afterwards like I just it
empowers me I feel you know I feel like
I've learned something I've grown I've
learned about a new culture learning
about a new person I always feel like I
can learn something new from someone no
matter who they are you know so ed M
with ideas like I you know I just love
I'm not afraid to fail you know for me
there's nothing more powerful than
creating something and if it's going
wrong like solving okay hop let's pivot
let's to figure out why it's not working
and continuing until you know we
actually built something that people you
know see value in and has grown and when
something does work the reward of like
seeing people come together for one
thing and everyone kind of believing in
that mission and believing in that idea
but leaving in it it's just like there's
nothing more rewarding to me that's like
that's it's its best moments of my life
have been like when I've taken a big
risk and I've seen it come to fruition
and like it's gone from this idea to
people to like action people like you
know all making it reality rule number
three have an abundance mindset if
something I'll talk about a lot cone
over analysis paralysis there's not
taking so many different opinions paying
attention to everything everybody has to
say about what about you what you should
be doing all of a sudden it can start to
paralyze you we're so over analyzing you
know and at the end of the day
entrepreneurship is about moving forward
taking action I mean teamwork with all
everyone's to play a role on the team
everyone should have a voice you just
take one little is this this one little
one one thing in the game one steal one
block one shot one pass one thing that
can shake momentum that can completely
change the game from you losing or
winning things always be talking about
this yesterday
three who it was but somebody who knew
Kobe Kobe was watching a video of a kid
in high school who had like one single
move that Kobe never saw he loved it so
he showed up early in Staples Center
right from this watching the kid in high
school and he started doing that move
over and over and over and over right
and as woman's like yo what are you
gonna stop practicing that move and he
said unto
that's it until you know what that meant
until he mastered it as men as long as
it took for him to master that one move
he would he was going to continue to
practice that movie
that's what you just have to do you have
to be early soap in that gym every
single day every single day put in that
work master your strengths know yourself
every single day
keep pushing forward right have that
abundance mentality make your team
better every single day and watch house
much that's manifesting for you and your
life personally and in business in your
career and then you'll have that true
success rule number four stay ahead of
the curve my fourth tip is all about
learning staying ahead of the curve by
every single day reading your pop
favorite publication doing research
about your industry or other like real
trendsetters in your industry you know I
can also be reading a book and you know
it from your favorite author or from
another entrepreneur and like learning
about their journey you never know when
you'll be able to find a nugget
whether that's researching online or
reading a book or even listening to a
podcast but you should consistently
every day make sure you're taking time
to push yourself to learn something new
rule number five focus on your strengths
as an entrepreneur you typically want to
do it all and a lot of times in the very
beginning you are wearing every at and
trying to do it all and you have to be
resourceful you have to be willing to
get your hands dirty and do a little bit
of everything in the beginning but then
it's like okay really buckle down and I
even had to go through this with myself
you know there was times I was like
trying to do too much I do trying to do
it all and like figure out like what am
I really really passionate about what am
I really great at what is that one thing
that I can do the very best on my team
to add the most value you know for the
you know for this idea of business and
then so figuring out okay who do who do
you really need you know do you need
that chief operating officer that person
that's gonna really help you with the
operations and logistics and the
infrastructure who do you need that you
know mark is someone that's gonna handle
your marketing that's just badass and
all they care about is like how they're
gonna be able to tell this story to the
marketplace and be able to retain people
that become customers and you know who
are the people that you need you know
around you and what are you really truly
great at rule number six believe in
yourself you can do whatever you want
today you started at
let's say you've lots of product you can
do whatever you want to become
successful if you believe in yourself if
you're willing to put in the work if
you're willing to grind if you're
willing to be passionate you're willing
to get out there there's no book there's
no movie there's no YouTube video that
will literally guide you to become
successful it's about you and what's
inside of you if you have what it takes
this is possible and I did it I did it
you can do it I was told that I wasn't
gonna make it I wasn't the smartest kid
I didn't know who's gonna add but I had
the fear failure I don't know what
tomorrow looks like I haven't certainty
just like all you but I never stopped
believing
I never every time I was dad or I had
doubts I'd pick myself back up I said I
would never give up I made myself that
promise you need to make yourself that
promise when you had that type of
commitment watch how much manifest in
your life watch how you transform into
somebody that's unbreakable that will
accomplish anything that you think and
dream of in your entire life
rule number seven get quality sleep if
you want to be an effective entrepreneur
you need to be able to have good quality
sleep this is the most important aspect
of making sure that you are running on
all cylinders the quality of your sleep
matters just as much if not more than
how long you sleep and for me as an
entrepreneur with so much on my mind all
the time you know I can't have a
mattress that causes me to toss and turn
the more rest I had the quality of sleep
no tossing and turning the comfort you
know it allows me to to make better
decisions have better energy the next
day just truly be the most efficient
girard that I could possibly be rule
number eight thrive under pressure I've
loved pressure
I love adversity I actually like through
I'm actually I perform better with
pressure in the air city for sure I
wasn't the kid who I was able to like
study for like the test when it came
time to take that test like
I'm like I get really focused and
prepared for that it says anything with
speaking engagements now you know like
I'm really bad at preparing from a TEDx
like people prepare for like months at
my TEDx I didn't prepare
I waited it was like the day of like
TEDx and I was about you know all right
it's game time I get focused and what is
it what is it that we want to accomplish
here what is the message that was great
cuz my mother was the first time my
mother showed up I dedicated it to my
mom but I always thrived a over
adversity and when I what are you saying
to yourself at this point like how do
you leverage the pressure is it just
literally subconscious and you show up
or are you saying like hey there's
pressure there's people that want to see
me fail there's no way I'm gonna let
this happen yeah um it's Steph Lee
subconscious just throughout my entire
life I've had moments like that where
I've almost even died you know exclu be
diving almost drowning and like my air
breaking and meeting me being like I'm
underwater right now I don't have air I
may die what's gonna happen and then
like lo and behold like somehow like the
person next to me like sees that I'm
choking and like boom gives me their air
and I'm like okay I get to the top well
we're like when I'm snowboarding
backcountry and you know my friends all
lose mean it gets dark and I'm in the
middle of the mountain and like I have
no helmet and I'm like I got to get to
the bottom of this mountain and there's
rocks and trees and I'm like okay could
you stuff together this is that first it
it's fine it's like you got to get down
this mountain you know I'm like it's
about my life I've had moments like this
happen and it's just like over time I
see that fear and I'm like I'm running
right through it you know there's
nothing that's gonna hold me just times
I'm flying in the plane I'm like this
plane may go down but you know I'm okay
with that I'm okay with dying like
that's because now it's like I'm doing I
know I'm doing everything I possibly can
every single day to inspire impact the
people around me and if I die I know
that I've done my part as much as I
possibly can rule number nine find
mentors my first semester I realized
that college was a big business and I
was like they're telling me what classes
to take and I wanted to learn how do I
learn how to invest how do I learn how
to start a business the first semester
people are partying whether they've been
in college and they were in high school
they're telling me what classes I was
like this is it for me and if I'm gonna
take a risk I should take it now there
is no book in the world of no classroom
in the world that will be able to teach
an entrepreneurship
having a mentor and being an apprentice
is literally invaluable for you to learn
how to actually start your own company
and become successful it was for me it
was for my last apprentice who went on
to build a company of over 200 people
selling 450 million dollars in three
years and it is for you and rule number
10 the last one before a very special
bonus clip is don't sleep walk through
life humanity is facing an epidemic we
are plagued by fear it has become the
predominant emotion of our planet
view of rejection fear is not being good
enough you're not being loved the fear
of failure
[Music]
but the fear that scares me the most is
that we continue to sleepwalk during our
short time here on earth never truly
waking up to make our dreams a reality
we have these fears and anxieties
because we swing on the pendulum a time
into the future into the past never
stopping to acknowledge the present you
see all of us are walking forward with
this mirror in front of us looking
backwards yeah all we really need to do
is look within stop looking out into the
world for answers and start looking
within yourself
the world is going through a massive
change our planet is shifting back into
a generation of consciousness and human
connection for this to happen we must
know that in order for us to change the
world we must change oneself
the day that you realize that you have
the ability to master your mind your
beliefs and your imagination will be the
moment that you experience the abundance
of what's truly possible in your world
this truth will be the most momentous of
your entire life it will be the day that
you initiate ownership of your destiny
understand that your feelings create
your thoughts your thoughts create your
feelings your feelings create your
actions and this is how you create your
reality
I got pulled over by all these cops I
was thought I was gonna go to jail and
why were you doing I was just a weed
okay but you know you know you could get
you get in trouble yeah you know what I
mean and I used to drive home from high
school and one of my one of the kids and
moms she was in her own apartment first
fort like ground floor and I was a
normal thing for me every single day
it's going to give her her you know her
20 it was like no big deal one day all
these cops pull up all around me and I'm
like this is it I'm month ago about to
get arrested I'm I support my family I'm
gonna disappoint my thing all these
dudes I'm gonna be that failure I'm
gonna be that that example what is this
gonna look like for it I kept my whole
life bro
but like quickly my reactions I had
tinted windows it was my friend's mom
the kid was on husband's I pull him off
and let go while he was his it was his
nickname
y'all Acosta here you gotta come outside
right now instead I'm picking you up
picking you up they hang up the phone
close the cops in my window next to no
flashlights Loma window I'm like I'm
just picking up my friend he came
outside like nah we go to high school
together and I just kid you not the
other cop goes not him
and right in front of me somebody was
coming to Grand Theft Auto and I saw
them arrest this kid in front of me in
the car in front of me and to me I was
like god it's a sign a guardian angel I
was felt it was a gonna find the cities
like hey you use that what you want you
like like this is there so much yeah
that was it that was my one chance if
I'm that mom afford I said I'm never
gonna do anything like this ever again
I'm gonna start channeling my hustle
mentality to business
I want to like you know I want to level
up raise your standard Apple at the core
its core value is that means that people
your passion can change the way people
not one drop of my self-worth depends on
your it's suppose to mean
if you liked this video and want more
inspiration check out the top ten girls
video I did on Tom bill you the link is
right there next to me I think you'll
enjoy it continue to believe and I'll
see you there the only credit I will
give myself is when other people break
and give up and stop I just don't